welcome to pft ot on yahoo sports peter
king i'm mike florio some of the big
news currently happening in the nfl the
dominoes are falling as teams hire new
coaches and the giants yesterday after
not hiring baylor coach matt rule we
thought that's where he would land he
lands in carolina the giants pivot
quickly to
joe judge special teams coordinator and
for one year receivers coach in new
england so peter did the giants get this
one right
well mike i
think there's one thing that they did
wrong in this and it could turn out
there were many things they did wrong
but of the things we know right now we
know
that joe judge did not have any other
suitors out there and the giants chose
to pick him before
finishing their interview process
and that means that they never
interviewed josh mcdaniels who some
would say is a far more accomplished
coordinator than joe judge was now they
did interview josh mcdaniels for their
head coaching job before they hired pat
shurmur
uh and uh so obviously they had a sense
of who josh mcdaniels was and so for
whatever reason they jumped all over joe
judge it surprised me quite honestly it
shocked me
but if the story is true
that they were given the option to match
the contract in carolina seven years 62
million
quite honestly
and and and uh and hire matt rule
quite honestly i don't blame the giants
at all for not doing that how can you
commit to do that before you've sat down
and interviewed a guy
so
we're gonna find out about joe judge i
i'm a little skeptical
but i didn't sit on on the interview
i've never met joe judge i've never
talked to joe judge
so i i think that everybody should
reserve their judgment no pun intended
until they see what this guy is all
about
well the good news for joe judge it's
not like he's following newt rockne and
vince lombardi in new york ben mcadoo
was bad and pat shurmur was worse so the
bar is low and he comes from new england
where he's seen a thing or two about how
to win championships i like the move but
i'm also nervous about the move because
of the fact that joe judge is a special
teams coordinator because i think
special teams coordinators should be
considered more frequently for head
coaching jobs they just aren't john
harbaugh has been phenomenal and he was
predominantly a special teams
coordinator before he became head coach
of the ravens he had one year as
defensive backs coach kind of to make
people not obsess over the fact that he
wasn't a real football coach i think if
judge does well it's going to reinforce
the idea that there should be more
special teams coordinators who get these
opportunities my concern though is peter
if he falls flat on his face people will
slam the door on hiring special teams
coordinators in the future
well i mean that's
in my opinion that's about the seventh
or eighth thing on the list at least as
far as i'm concerned the new york giants
this is a vital
choice for the giants
we don't know at this point
who is joe judge bringing along as his
coordinators because right now that is a
huge part of this situation
who is going to coach the franchise
quarterback is he any good you know
who's going to be your defensive
coordinator who's going to do that you
saw that when brian flores left the
patriots this year
he brought along
chad o'shea and then fired him as his
offensive coordinator didn't bring him
originally as that but you know he
became the offensive coordinator during
the preseason uh you know because
basically caldwell could not coach this
year jim caldwell so
i i just want to know
who he's bringing with him and how good
they're going to be at their jobs
yeah i agree with you and it makes it
more critical because he is a special
teams coordinator it's not like he
carries in that experience as an
offensive guru or a defensive guru he's
got to find guys he can delegate those
two very important aspects of the the
overall uh roster too while he uh
presumably will continue to keep a hand
in special teams coordination because
he's uh he's been good enough at it to
become an nfl head coach so big
questions for the new york giants and
big concerns for their fans as they try
to get the team back to what it was not
all that long ago but it feels like a
lot longer than eight years since that
team was performing at a very high level
for more pft ot yahoo videos check us
out throughout the nfl season which will
be ending before we know it
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports